on va à prendre le pouls d'un malade qui
se porte pas très bien pendant cette
prochaine demi heure ce malade c'est le
climat l'année qui vient de s'achever
l'a encore montré incendies de forêt en
suède canicule record en europe fonte
des glaciers
voilà pour le diagnostic sur le terrain
du côté des remèdes politique on est
plutôt frileux en suisse la révision de
la loi sur le co2 a été tout simplement
coulé par le conseil national début
décembre
la coop 24 de katowice et accouché d'un
accord sans effusion pour appliquer
l'accord de paris et l'engagement de
limiter à 2 degrés le réchauffement
climatique d'ici à la fin du siècle
alors dans ce contexte peut-on encore
agir pour le climat inverser la tendance
et si oui comment on va le voir jusqu'à
8 heures avec notre invité bonjour jean
marc jancovici
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être en duplex
avec nous de notre studio de paris
vous êtes ingénieur français chef
d'entreprise consultant président aussi
du think tank de shift project qui
s'engage pour la transition énergétique
vous êtes aussi depuis quelques semaines
membres du tout nouveau haut conseil
pour le climat auprès du premier
ministre français edouard philippe
et puis on vous connaît essentiellement
pour votre travail de sensibilisation et
de vulgarisation sur les thèmes de
l'énergie et du climat voilà beaucoup de
casquettes
on est le 3 janvier jean marc jancovici
en pleine période de bonnes résolutions
et ce qu'on peut encore en prendre pour
le climat
la réponse est oui et non vous avez dans
le système climatique énormément de
processus physique avec beaucoup
beaucoup d'inertie
à commencer par le premier d'entre eux
qui est que quand on rajoute du co2 dans
l'air ça mais très très longtemps avant
que ces purs et le co2 est un oxyde les
vieux souvenirs de chimie de certains
d'entre vous vous rappelleront peut-être
que les oxydes sont des molécules très
très stable et une fois qu'on a mis du
dioxyde de carbone dans l'atmosphère le
surplus concret mais des milliers
d'années avant de finir par ces purées
donc si demain matin on arrête les
émissions totalement il faudra que
l'humanité attendre des milliers
d'années avant que l'atmosphère ne
revienne à la concentration de co2
qu'ils avaient avant le début de nos
activités industrielles
quand vous avez un pas de temps pareil
devant vous une inertie pareil eh bien
vous avez nécessairement d effet engagé
qui ne sont pas réversible donc si
demain matin on arrête les émissions
vous avez quand même des conséquences
qui vont continuer à augmenter
alors j'en cite deux ou trois qui vont
durer très
longtemps la hausse du niveau des océans
va durer des milliers d'années encore
après l'arrêt des émissions et ne serait
ce que pour la fonte des glaces du reste
l'un étant lié à l'autre va aussi duré
pendant encore quelques siècles à
quelques milliers d'années après l'arrêt
des émissions
il faut savoir que si on dépasse les 2
les fameux de degrés qui ont été évoqués
à l'accord de paris eh bien il suffit
d'attendre et les pays-bas finiront sous
les eaux donc vision plutôt pessimiste
pas vraiment possible de prendre de
bonnes résolutions si je vous comprends
bien bas elles sont pour partie déjà
derrière nous c'est un peu comme si vous
vous disiez quand j'aurai 15 ans voilà
ce que je ferai vous pouvez le dire si
vous voulez mais ça n'a aucune portée
physique est bien en ce qui concerne le
climat il ya un certain nombre de choses
pour lesquelles le comment dire le coup
est parti et donc on va devoir vivre
avec des conséquences croissante
maintenant à tout moment on peut
toujours limiter les conséquences qu'on
aura devant nous à l'avenir
donc quel que soit le moment où on
décide d'agir cette action finira par
avoir de l'effet mais elle finira pas
avoir de l'effet dans un horizon de
temps qui malheureusement dépasse les
échéances politiques et c'est ça le
drame de cette affaire juste avant le
début de notre discussion vous avez
parlé d'un sujet politique le mandat
politique classique ces quelques années
or il se trouve que là quoi qu'on fasse
le climat des 20 prochaines années est
prescrit c'est à dire que si on commence
à agir de manière forte aujourd'hui ça
va changer ce qui va se passer après
pour dire les choses simplement d'ici là
ça ne va à peu près rien changer et ça
c'est un drame pour les démocraties
occidentales
c'est là tout le paradoxe aujourd'hui de
cette situation l'urgence sur le terrain
et en face cet immobilisme politique qui
a poussé d'ailleurs à un certain nicolas
hulot à prendre cette décision souvenez
vous je vais prendre pour la première
fois la décision la plus difficile de ma
vie je ne veux plus me mentir je veux
pas donner l'illusion que ma présence au
gouvernement signifie qu'on est à la
hauteur sur ces enjeux là et donc je
prends la décision de quitter le
gouvernement
la démission radiophonique on s'en
souvient c'était le 28 août dernier sur
les ondes de france inter de l'ancien
ministre transition de la transition
écologique en france nicolas hulot avec
qui vous avez travaillé un jeu croit
jean marc jancovici et il a eu raison de
partir nicolas hulot on me pardonnera ce
commentaire c'est un épiphénomène
la raison de fond en fait pour laquelle
on a tant de mal à lutter contre le
changement climatique c'est ce qui a
rendu la suisse si riche
ça s'appelle les combustibles fossiles
rappelez-vous au sortir de la dernière
guerre mondiale la suisse est un pays
très pauvre
les suisses font partie des habitants
les plus pauvres d'europe et ce qui a
totalement changé le statut de la suisse
ça s'appelle le pétrole le gaz et le
charbon
c'est à dire des choses qui permettent
de mettre des machines au travail et de
créer une valeur ajoutée
considérablement plus importante que
quand c'était les hommes qui
travaillaient aujourd'hui une bonne
partie de l'économie suisse tirent
profit de ces combustibles toutes les
activités financières profitent en fait
d'activités qui ont lieu ailleurs que
sur le sol suisse mais dont vous
récupérez la valeur ajoutée toutes les
activités à l'exportation aux besoins de
transport sans lesquels vous pouvez pas
vendre ailleurs toutes les activités de
négoce vous avez des normes société de
négoce en suisse même si elles sont pas
cotées c'est également et des activités
minières soffin de ma part donc c'est
des métis exerce ailleurs donc le drame
de cette affaire c'est que l'indicateur
roi sur lequel on n'arrête pas de jeter
notre regard et notre amour qui
s'appelle l'argent est bien pour le
faire augmenter il faut augmenter la
quantité d'énergie qu'on utilise et donc
les émissions déjà drame et c'est ça le
drame et on en revient à l équation
difficile à résoudre
économie et écologie est ce que on peut
être en même temps pro business et pro
planète jean marc jancovici très
difficilement au moment où on a créé les
indicateurs de farrou on a créé le
système de l'économie classique qui est
celui aujourd'hui qu'on utilise et dont
les prix sont directement
la conséquence est bien on a dit on va
s'intéresser qu'aux seuls facteurs
limitants qui importe vraiment c'était
il ya deux siècles
c'est à dire ce qui vient des hommes
donc il ya deux siècles la nature est
immense la terre est immense enfin fait
la même le diamètre qu'aujourd'hui elles
apprennent à l'époque on a l'impression
que c'est très très grand et donc on
s'est dit la seule chose qu'on va
regarder c'est le travail humain est
capital humain donc quand le garagiste
que vous avez interviewé juste avant une
voiture en fait tout ce qu'il vend c'est
une somme de revenus humain personne ne
paye le faire qui a été extrait de la
croûte terrestre et qui a servi à faire
la voiture celui là il nous a été donné
gratuitement par la nature quand on est
rentré sur la planète terre il y avait
du minerai de fer et personne n'a rien
payé pour l'existence de ce minerai de
fer de même personne n'a rien payé pour
l'existence du pétrole personne n'a rien
payé pour l'existence du système
climatique personne n'a rien payé pour
l'existence de la dent blanche et de la
jungfrau enfin je veux dire tout ça est
gratuit et il ya qu a littéralement se
baisser pour le ramasser
aujourd'hui donc quand on fait croître
les indicateurs économiques
en fait on ne compte nulle part le fait
qu'on va consommer une partie de la
planète terre pour produire les objets
que nous fabriquons et les services qui
en découle donc l'accession gâteau elle
passe par quoi jean marc jancovici par
une période nécessaire de décroissance à
terme forcément on va devoir aller par
là alors on va la voir de toute façon ça
c'est la bonne nouvelle est la seule
question c'est est ce qu'on le choisit
ou est ce qu on le subit alors pourquoi
est-ce qu'on va l'avoir de toute façon
parce que ce qu'on a coutume d'appeler
la croissance vers la croissance de la
production économique en fait c'est la
croissance de la transformation de
ressources naturelles en autre chose
plus de voiture c'est plus de minerai de
fer extrait plus de pétrole consommé et
c est ça sur une planète finie ça peut
pas durer indéfiniment peut pas avoir
indéfiniment plus d'extraction de tout
ce qui est matériel donc là soit on ne
gère pas ce qu'on veut limiter les
effets à laval donc les effets
environnementaux et notamment la
question du changement climatique
soit on dit on veut pas donc temps que
le temps que la fête continue tant que
ça augmente et ma foi on augmente
sauf qu'à un moment on sera rattrapé par
la patrouille puisqu'on ne peut pas
augmenter indéfiniment tout les
extractions en provenance de la planète
qui faisait treize mille kilomètres de
diamètre ya deux siècles elle fait
toujours 13 8 kilomètres de diamètre
aujourd'hui et on commence à voir les
signes avant avancé de cet essoufflement
et en particulier l'un des signes qu'on
voit c'est que la quantité de capital
qu'il faut investir pour extraire une
unité de quelque chose de la croûte
terrestre
une tonne de cuivre une tonne d'argent
une tonne de pétrole etc
ce capital augmente de manière
significative et ça c'est le marqueur
d'une raréfaction de la ressource
beaucoup plus confiants pris son prix a
pas beaucoup d'intérêt qui montre que le
système est déjà en train de
s'essouffler et en fait en europe depuis
2007 et dans la zone ocde de manière
plus large donc au japon et aux etats
unis également
on a déjà commencé à observer un
ralentissement très fort lié à cette
difficulté croissante
d'approvisionnement en matières
premières
sauf qu'aujourd'hui on n'a pas vraiment
pris ce virage énergétique là on l'a
encore vu l'année passée en 2010 cette
part par le retrait des états unis de
l'accord de paris la chine qui reste le
plus gros producteur mondial de co2
aujourd'hui comment convaincre les
politiques comment amorcer ce virage
énergétique
vous savez si on regarde l'empreinte
carbone d'un suisse c'est à dire la
totalité des émissions qui lui
permettent d'avoir les produits et
services qu'ils utilisent
on n'est pas très très loin des
etats-unis parce que les suisses
utilisent beaucoup l'avion les suisses
achètent beaucoup de produits qui ne
sont pas fabriqués chez eux par exemple
à votre constructeur automobile en
suisse mais quand vous achetez une
voiture vous achetez 5 à 6 tonnes de
théo de co2 pardon par tonne de voiture
les suisses achètent de l'électronique
qui n'est pas fabriqué chez vous et
c'est donc vous avez l'empreinte carbone
d'un suisse qui est un habitant riches
de la planète et pas très très éloignée
de celle d'un américain
par ailleurs pour m'intéresser un tout
petit peu à la politique énergétique de
votre pays pour le moment vous avez
décidé que vous ne remplacerez riez pas
vos centrales nucléaires vous avez pas
dit pourquoi vous les remplacent seriez
plus exactement il ya un doute
alors si on peut doubler nombre de
barrages en suisse ça va bien question
co2 mais si on remplace sa part des
centrales à gaz les émissions
augmenteront ça c'est une voie à suivre
selon vous la sortie du nucléaire
décidée par la suisse
en 2011 si on veut pas augmenter le co2
que on a décidé de longer pas une voie à
suivre
c'est très clair on a les arbitrages à
faire dans cette histoire ya pas de
solution miracle un tout à l'heure on a
dit qu'une des solutions c'était la
décroissance je ne pense pas que tout le
monde saute en l'air de joie quand on
dit ça donc ya pas de solution facile en
ce qui concerne la lutte contre le
changement climatique
et c'est la raison pour laquelle vous
avez énuméré en ouverture de cette
session un certain nombre de choses qui
ont l'air de patiner mais c'est
justement parce que c'est quelque chose
de pas facile si c'était facile il ya
longtemps que le problème serait réglé
alors c'est pas facile des solutions va
falloir quand même on trouve et c'est
peut-être d'ailleurs ce que vous allez
faire au sein de ce haut conseil pour le
climat qui est tout jeune il a été créé
il y a quelques semaines en france en
pleine crise des gilet jaune par le
gouvernement de hun d'edouard philippe
vous avez été nommé donc membres de ce
haut conseil pour le climat à quoi ça va
servir c'est un comité d'experts en plus
vous allez avoir les moyens concrètement
de faire des choses alors pour le moment
le texte qui doit préciser exactement
notre action n'est pas encore sorti donc
on sait ce qui ce qu'on attend de nous
normalement ce qu'on attend de nous
c'est de donner un avis une fois que
j'ai dit ça j'ai tout dit et j'ai rien
dit parce qu'un avis c'est quelque chose
qu'on peut donner en deux phrases comme
en un rapport de 500 pages et on a des
avis sur le climat de la part des
experts je je je le redis le climat
enfin le changement climatique est une
conséquence de l'utilisation de
l'énergie l'énergie c'est ce qui a
permis de mettre les machines au travail
c'est à dire ce qui a permis le monde
moderne la totalité du monde moderne
qu'on est en train d'observer autour de
nous si les machines et l'énergie
n'existait pas cette session en duplex
par exemple n'aurait pas lieu les radios
sur lesquels vos auditeurs nous écoutent
n'aurait pas été fabriqués les voitures
dans lesquelles ils sont peut-être en
train de nous écouter ce qui est très
bien évidemment n'existerait pas plus
donc quand on s'intéresse au climat je
le redis on s'intéresse à la totalité de
ce qui a fait le monde moderne
donc effectivement avoir un avis sur la
totalité du monde moderne ça peut
prendre quelques centaines de pages
comme deux phrases
alors une fois que j'ai dit ça qu'est ce
qu'on attend de nous on a les choses qui
sont déjà précisé
c'est un avis tous les ans un rapport
formel tous les cinq ans
probablement quelque chose qui est un
avis sur la pertinence des politiques et
mesures décidées par la france
mais là aussi entre avoir comme avis ça
ne permet pas de faire le job et il
aurait fallu faire ceci il ya une marge
parce que la première qu'on sait que la
première conclusion pardon est plus
facile à prendre de manière qu'on plus
consensuel que la deuxième mais ce sera
pas là une commission alibi pour donner
une bonne conscience écolo au
gouvernement macron il y aura
nécessairement un peu de ça quand quand
notre cher président pour le moment il
nous a pas donné des signes évidents
comme quoi il avait parfaitement compris
le problème est qu'ils avaient décidé de
s'y attaquer de manière extrêmement
déterminé donc si c'est évident que dans
la création de cette instance
il ya quelque chose qui relève de
l'effet de façade c'est absolument et je
crois que personne n'est dupe au sein du
duo conseil après ça sera quand même un
petit peu ce qu'on arrivera en fer et en
particulier un des éléments importants
ça sera la portée médiatique qu on nous
a dit parce que nous vivons dans un
monde dans lequel les médias ont une
importance majeure sur la structuration
de la décision publique enfin en tout
cas en france
donc ce qui se passe sur les antennes
des radios et sur les écrans de
télévision a beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
d'importance sur ce qui se passera
ensuite dans la tête des gens qui
prennent des décisions